before getting into the best of this
episode in which Joel Tess and Ellie
have to maneuver through a museum of
clickers I want to acknowledge the cold
open again I find it really interesting
the direction that Craig Mason is going
for the start of these episodes because
it feels like the book for World War Z
so far this is also assuming that this
continues to be the case for the
following episodes but in the book World
War Z it was essentially a collection of
different points of views throughout the
world during a zombie outbreak it was a
great read because it offered a lot of
variety and substance because every
perspective the book explored was unique
so the last of us so far is kind of
going down this route because we have
two new and original perspectives that
further expand upon the world for this
one it was intriguing to see the initial
start of the outbreak and to have
someone explain with expertise and fully
educate the audience as to how someone
gets infected and for it to be more
believable which makes the scenario even
more realistic and thus scary Craig
Mason again is great at hitting you with
this gut punch feeling of dread in which
the scientists have acknowledges that
this is an extinction level event and
advises the military officer to bomb the
city truly a crushing form of advice
that the scientist gives but she knows
it's necessary to save the world and
this even has a callback in the episode
where Joel Ellie and Tess come across a
crater for this cold open it obviously
isn't in the game because it would
destroy any sort of momentum in the
gameplay if you cut to some random
scientist halfway across the world
however for the show you don't have to
constantly keep the player engaged with
action for the point where we're at in
the show there were about seven action
set pieces in the game thus far so I saw
some people complaining about there not
being enough action and the show was
boring in comparison but do you realize
how much that would ruin the tense
nature of the show for Action to be
satisfying there has to be Stakes for it
builds up and by having too much of it
you lose out on character development
opportunities especially in the show
that is more of a tense Thriller
survival if you are constantly having
Joel kill dozens of infected and in
every other scene then the factor of
danger starts to diminish because the
show would now be establishing the main
character as an action hero for the game
you kind of are that but you have to
keep in mind how many times you died
while playing the game assuming what
difficulty you played on because I hate
to break it to some people but you can't
respond in a TV show along with the fact
that Joel had an extremely hard time
killing one clicker so the mechanics in
which you keep the player slash viewer
scared for the well-being of the
character work differently one is
grounded in realism that we are forced
to watch and be on the edge of our seats
while the other one is more of a
challenging experience and punishes you
if you die the show not having hours
worth of action is not a bad thing and
if anything is a great benefit that the
show takes advantage of any of that lost
time in terms of the game's length is
converted into original scenes Craig
Mason is able to simultaneously turn the
reduction of action into a double
positive because it frees up time for
new material and it gives the show a
better pace and allows the infected to
be more intimidating because we aren't
constantly mowing them down and we can
use them in more of a horror angle also
through the show Joel's able to have a
deeper impact through whom killing
ephedra officer in the game he
essentially killed dozens of them and as
a player you become desensitized to that
violence
the show is able to make Joel even more
human because he's dealing with the
emotional consequences of taking one
human life and to also do this you need
that good Pace within the script so that
we can have character focused scenes
after big events as an example this
scene where Joel and Tess are observing
to see if Ellie turns wasn't in the game
it creates this balanced flow so that
the characters can properly process and
react to What recently happened and
again this is a great original scene
it's filled with good character-focused
conflict because they don't buy the fact
that she's actually immune and it offers
Ellie to try to disarm their fears with
a funny moment
don't
then before going into the terrifying
scene with the clickers I want to gush
about how beautiful the production
design inside decoration is in the show
I was really excited to see how it was
going into this episode but it
thoroughly exceeded my expectations with
how insanely detailed and worn down
every square inch of this world is from
Vines and vegetation covering almost
every surface flooded areas animals
roaming dilapidated structures fungus
sprawling from decomposing corpses
gorgeous Vistas that are aided by
seamless and abundant VFX and a frog
that knows how to play the piano this
show is completely astounding as to how
detailed the world is and I'm dying to
know how much this aspect alone costed
HBO in terms of the budget because off
of looking it up each episode has a
budget of somewhere in the range of 10
to 15 million and it's really paying off
with that magnificent aspect of the show
out of the way let's finally get into
the clicker scene to say that the scene
was just scary or tense would be an
understatement because there are so many
aspects that make this a perfect horror
and action scene from the prior setup of
our characters being like oh [__]
there's a variant in the building the
false sense of success that our
characters gain when they navigated
through this mad house until the Unlucky
collapse of a roof near them the really
slow build up of the clickers making
their way to our protagonists and US
hearing them not giving the audience a
clearer view of the clickers to make us
even more terrified of the unknown the
genius set location where there are
glass cases in which you can see
clickers pass by on the other side the
atmosphere of the room being dark and
foggy with the flashlights barely making
out the moving subjects our characters
being absolutely scared to the bone that
they're about to die and the final
release of tension into chaotic action
with the close-up of the clicker
screaming was amazing every single
aspect within the scene is perfect and
is all intelligently designed to elevate
the horror I also love how the
characters didn't even knock anything
over to alert the clickers and was
purely just from Ellie breathing too
hard it makes them that much more
terrifying when they can hear breathing
because it's almost impossible to
suppress that then the action segment
was just as good as the horror builds up
because of how hard these clickers were
to overcome that's one issue within the
game because you have an ability in
which you miraculously get echolocation
in which you can see every zombie
through walls this essentially destroys
any scary aspect within the game when
you're trying to stealth because it's
much easier when you have Wall hacks
however in the show Joel doesn't have
superhuman x-ray vision and they have to
pray to God that they don't get found by
the clickers another thing that you may
not realize is that reloading your gun
can make noise one of my favorite
moments in this scene was Joel slowly
trying to reload and minimizing his
noise while the clicker slowly
approaches him the cinematography of
this moment AIDS the suspense because
the camera moves to a close-up on Joel
as the frame leaves out the clicker we
don't know how close it's getting we
essentially enter Joel's frightened
perspective and then move with him as we
reveal the clicker again and even the
pesky glass from the game that you can
step on makes an appearance and quickly
turns the scene into a helpless struggle
if the rest of the show is able to
consistently execute scenes of this
caliber then I can honestly find no
Faults like this is just unmatched
quality that has every aspect of
production firing on all cylinders to
deliver one of the best visual products
on the market right now then obviously
the narrative continues to hit some
great beats in which Tess actually got
bit and is forced to stay behind and
kill the infected an interesting change
here is that Craig Mason made it to
where the fungus is a single organism
that can be alerted miles away if he
step on its tendrils it makes for a
great mechanic to further increase the
suspense because the characters are
screwed if they happen to step on it
even Neil druckman admitted that this
was a change that he loved episode 2 of
The Last of Us continues the outstanding
opening of the season and manages to
create one of the most scary and intense
scenes in a zombie movie or show in a
long time and to think that the show is
already seeming like it's peaking now is
a crazy thing because there are still so
many great sequences to come this
episode proves that the first episode's
quality wasn't a fluke and again the
execution is practically perfect thank
you for watching and let me know what
you thought about this episode in the
comments